hey this is pressure Walker reminding
you to mind your decisions start with
the rectangle whose sides are four and
eight draw a semicircle along the longer
side of the rectangle and now connect a
diagonal of the rectangle what is the
area of this shape shown in red I think
Xavier and Shanghai and everyone who
emailed me this problem this had gone
viral in China on Wei Bois can you
figure it out give this problem a try
and when you're ready keep watching the
video for a solution so how can we solve
for the area of this red shape we'll
solve it using the following equation
the area of the red shape is equal to
the area of this right triangle minus
the area of this green shape minus the
area of this circular segment so let's
solve for the area of each of these
shapes the right triangle is relatively
straightforward the area is its base
times its height all over 2 so we take 4
times 8 and divided by 2 to get 16 so
now let's solve for the area of this
green shape how can we do that well
let's focus on the following equation
the area this green shape will be the
area of this square minus the area of
this circular sector so let's solve for
the area of each of these shapes well
the square has a side length of 4 so
it's area will be 16 the other shape is
a quarter circle with the radius of 4
its area will be 0.25 x pi x 4 squared
this simplifies to be 4 pi so this green
shape has an area that's equal to 16
minus 4 pi so now let's simplify some of
the results we've already established
we'll take the area of the right
triangle and subtract the area of this
green shape to get sick
tene minus the quantity 16 minus 4 pi
this simplifies to be 4 pi all that
remains is to solve for the area of this
circular segment how can we do that this
is the most complicated part of the
problem this area will be equal to the
area of this circular sector minus the
area of this isosceles triangle in order
to solve for each of these shapes we're
gonna need to know the central angle so
let's label this angle as theta this
angle will also be equal to theta
because this is an isosceles triangle
notice the sides opposite these angles
are each radii of this circular sector
so this means the central angle of this
circular sector is equal to PI minus 2
theta so let's put in these dimensions
for the circular sector we can solve for
the area of the circular sector it'll be
4 squared over 2 multiplied by this
central angle now the area of the
isosceles triangle can be solved by
considering the dimensions and using the
formula 4 squared over 2 multiplied by
the sine of the angle in between so now
we need to solve for this angle well
let's focus on this right triangle theta
will be equal to the inverse tangent of
4 over 8 which is also equal to the
inverse tangent of 0.5 so now let's
simplify the area of this isosceles
triangle sine of PI minus 2 theta is
equal to the sine of 2 theta well then
use the double angle formula and we can
simplify it as follows so we now need to
know the sine of theta and the cosine of
theta in order to do that let's consider
this right triangle well solve for the
hypotenuse using the Pythagorean theorem
and then we can directly solve for the
sine and the cosine of this angle theta
we multiply those together and it
simplifies to be 0.4 so we substitute
that in and we can solve for the area of
this isosceles triangle
it'll be equal to 6 point 4 we can then
use theta is equal to the inverse
tangent of 0.5 to solve for the area of
this circular sector we're going to need
to sell
stitute that in to this to theta we now
simplify this formula and it all ends up
being the following so now we take four
pi and we subtract the area of this
circular segment and that'll be the area
of this red shape so we're going to do
some algebra and we simplify it and we
get the answer of sixteen multiplied by
the inverse tangent of 0.5 plus six
point four minus four pi and that's
approximately equal to one point two
five two so that's one way that we can
solve this problem there's another way
you could have approached it as well
let's put in a coordinate system and
consider solving this using calculus
this point is equal to four zero and
this point is equal to 0 for the
semicircle will have the following
equation and the diagonal will have the
equation y is equal to x over two so now
we can set up two integrals to solve for
the area notice the first area will be
the area of a right triangle going up to
X is equal to one point six and then the
rest will be this curved shape going
from one point six to four so we end up
that the area is equal to the sum of
these two integrals
now the first integral will be the area
of a right triangle so we can solve for
this using the area of a right triangle
and that'll simplify quite nicely so we
don't have to calculate this integral we
can just put in the area of point six
four as this first integral so how do we
solve the rest of this equation well
let's focus on this integral well split
it up into two different integrals the
first integral is trivial to calculate
the second integral we will ultimately
solve using a trigonometric substitution
but first let's do one more
simplification let's write U is equal to
X minus four so the integral becomes the
following we now need to do a
trigonometric substitution so we're
going to say U is equal to four
multiplied by the sine of theta so then
D U is equal to four times the cosine of
theta D theta we substitute this in and
we change the limits of integration
and then it'll be pretty straightforward
to calculate this
this simplifies to be 8 times the
inverse sine of 0.6 plus 3 point 8 4
so finally we now substitute the sin and
we simplify so that we get the area is
equal to 6 point 4 minus 8 times the
inverse sine of 0.6 and this is also
equal to the exact same answer which is
approximately one point two five two now
you might notice something interesting
this is one form of our answer using
integrals and this was the other form we
derived using trigonometry how are they
equal to each other here's a fantastic
proof by nesterova
start out with the right triangle whose
legs are 1 & 2 let this angle equal
alpha so that alpha is equal to the
inverse tangent of 0.5 now reflect this
triangle along the longer side now solve
for the hypotenuse of this right
triangle and it will be equal to 5
divided by the square root of 5 let's
drop an altitude along this triangle to
the other hypotenuse this angle over
here will be equal to 0.5 pi minus 2
alpha furthermore we can solve for the
altitude and it will be equal to 4
divided by the square root of 5 you can
solve for this because you know the area
the entire triangle is 2 and you know
that the base of this altitude is 5
divided by the square root of 5 so you
can then solve for the length or the
altitude we can then solve for the leg
in this right triangle as 3 divided by
the square root of 5 by the Pythagorean
theorem so now in this right triangle we
have a 3 4 5 right triangle this means
0.5 pi minus 2 alpha is equal to the
inverse sine of 0.6 we multiply both
sides by negative 8 and substitute in
for alpha to get the exact equation that
we need and this will show the
equivalence of the two different
solutions it's a pretty neat problem
thanks for watching these math videos
available for free on YouTube build
confidence for students and inspire
mathematical discovery for viewers
around the world
they have over 100 million views and the
channel has over 1 million subscribers
please subscribe for 480 of the newest
videos and even Li a puzzle or math
topic fresh and my
your decisions accom if you so choose
you can check out my merchandise on
teespring you can check out my books
listed in the video description and you
can support me on patreon thanks for
watching and thanks for your support